[Music]  oh hi  let me get this for you yes okay  all right help us oh no it's just swell  [Music]  i don't smell dinner being made  don't worry sweetheart i was just  keeping it covered for you  okay good  because i want it now  [Music]  why is this not open  oh  it's quite all right i know  i know  [Music]  hi honey  let me help you oh thank you  so how was work oh work was great i  actually um i got promoted oh my god  yep vice president congratulations  thanks  [Music]  in here  dinner's ready  that looks amazing greg but i already  ate at work so just save it for later oh  dang it  here  [Music]  opener  got it good luck honey  thanks anyway  absolutely  [Laughter]  no no  [Music]